most of turkeys Kurds live in the rugged
mountainous southeastern part of the
country it's an inhospitable environment
for both man and beast life here is hard
the shim checks chose to live in town
but not because their village al aqah so
poor what keeps them away our memories
of a horrible crime committed here
almost two decades ago look tell Erica
LarryBoy leaders soldiers dragged my
father out of the house at five in the
morning all the men of the village were
driven together and tied up high ball a
loser they were held all night without
food and water absentee then they were
taken away in a helicopter show your
soldiers then set fire to all the houses
in the village they told us to get out
we went to a barn to seek shelter but
later they burnt that down to for 10
years Dilber shim shek hoped she would
someday see her husband again until one
day a goatherd got in touch with her
Phillips you so g gu he found a mass
grave a few kilometers from you leaning
among the bonus no I found shreds of a
pullover that I'd knitted for my husband
then I added our [ __ ] he could still see
the bullet holes in it in the [ __ ]
groans in the 1990s this part of the
country was the site of a brutal civil
war between Turkish and government
forces and gorillas of the Kurdish
Workers Party or PKK just saying the
word Kurdistan was enough to land a
person in jail arrests torture and
political assassinations were daily
occurrences today the guns have been
silenced and the Turkish government is
negotiating with the Kurds after 30
years of civil war the PKK is
withdrawing its forces from Turkey
aztlán shrimp Shack has yet to receive
official confirmation of his father's
death that's why he demonstrates with
relatives of other Kurds who disappeared
or been murdered they protest each
Saturday in the city of da Bahia the
officer alleged to have ordered the
kidnapping and murder of his father and
ten other Kurtz is due to appear in
court an unprecedented development in
Turkey we know that one officer alone
could never have ordered killings like
that single-handedly the orders for
these crimes against Kurds came from the
very top that needs to be set straight
in the tangency the Turkish army used to
be well-respected human rights
violations were long excused by the
fight against terror or blamed on the
PKK but now it's coming to light that
extreme nationalists even order killings
within their own ranks bakhtiar iden was
a highly decorated turkish general
active in the southeastern part of the
country he was assassinated in 1993 his
daughter and widow have always seen him
as a martyr who fell in the battle
against Kurdish enemies of Turkey now
it's been revealed that he was possibly
killed by his own comrades in arms
rather than the PKK prosecutors have
filed charges they say iden was killed
because he was unwilling to take brutal
measures in the fight against the Kurds
the allegations are a shock to his
family awesome on she did she did the
military leadership hasn't said a single
word about the latest charges five years
ago they said the investigation was over
and it was a cut-and-dried case I don't
want to believe it was someone from the
army you should me really ought to see
sting if that turns out to be true our
whole world will collapse the news
aghast ahead either you kill them skin
do DJ she may never find out a 20-year
statute of limitations on the crimes of
the 1990s could bring the investigations
to an abrupt halt human rights activists
are demanding that law be changed that
would be a good step the other good step
would be to really you know winds and
some groups talk about truth
Commission's we've also
recommended an independent kind of truth
commission which wouldn't prevent the
prosecution of perpetrators but would it
you know encourage the process but the
relatives of the victims remain wary
butta better policy on this won't be
possible unless the political killings
that took place back then are cleared up
again into that cake ready to play
bodega taste without justice would be
inconceivable for our family is good
look on desura but it's our dreams were
destroyed back then risky we've been
living with that for 20 years miss a
piane style are merciful miss hear me
look trauma sania shooters turkey is
finally facing up to its recent past but
the only thing certain about the process
is that it's a traumatic one because you
don't say